you wear crop tops i like that you like
that stuff oh my gosh no i see a man on
a crop top oh no
it's not toxic masculinity
it is not toxic masculinity to have a
preference for men that are men sorry
i'm
i think you're more masculine am i a man
just because i'm wearing pants oh are
you a what is that i am i don't know
because i wear pink well i did yeah
pants are more masculine basketball
shorts are more math like you look more
masculine when you wear that stuff men
tend to be more excited
when you say you dance upset for that
like why does it yeah if you wear the
baggy shorts like basketball kit wise
why does it mean i'm more masculine do
you know what i mean because you look
like like it's like common sense
sexuality that's not coming to be like
social i could wear a salmon shirt
blue jeans and just
a salmon pink shirt that means i'm
feminine
well i mean not just a pink shirt it's
like how you dress like i think it's
common sense that a girl in a ball gown
looks more feminine and a girl in a
basketball jersey i think it looks more
massive
i don't i don't think it's security i
think it's common sense like i think
like come on you guys know what i'm
saying it's true
you're telling me you're telling me
cinderella cinderella
looks more masculine
than a wnba
yeah it's more matte like girls look
more masculine in our basketball journey
i wear them i wear them
so if a guy so if a guy comes to me in a
crop top he looks more feminine i'm not
attracted to elliot looks real good
wait there are exceptions to everywhere
if i was in a football kit you'll be
saying oh i look more masculine yeah
yeah because typically
that is
but like
the world we live in see this is where
society's standards come in i feel like
personally to my in my opinion your
opinions
don't get too yeah it's wrong yeah i
just feel like personally we're in a
world that's more evolved where back in
the day yes football and basketball are
sports that's more associated with
men
and women have worked their asses off
their bloody asses of i'm trying to
swear guys um to get to where they are
the level of where they are for example
i haven't had an argument with a guy
that said one of the girls on your team
um plays like a guy and i argued with
him and i was like yo why does she play
that many times because why does she
play do you think because men are better
no
sorry
hold on they are yes i'm talking hold on
because i'm going to
like statistically in every category in
every sorry physically scientifically
yeah
so by every measure that you get every
piece of data that you can measure and
then win muscles and the muscle
it's
this girl worked her ass off to get to
the standard of basketball uh-huh that
she played she's a pro player yeah yeah
and the guy said she plays like a guy
that's so degrading she worked her ass
off to get to where she plays i think
that's degrading but she looks like a
woman is that something about who she is
it's not even about women or men but why
is it why is it degrading if men are bad
like they're better because why would
you prepare me
that's a whole different level better
men are okay okay okay okay this is this
is this is nothing this is men
men are not in the conversation when
with that kind of thing like her working
her ass off and getting to that point
like to bring a man into that it's
almost like why because like
okay this is my platform this is my this
is my youtube show pipe down child
respectfully
like why does it matter like why is your
first instinct to get angry when men are
like if we compare if we compare men to
women like they don't get angry like why
is your first so
because they don't want to be
comfortable like femininity being pinned
on them
and we
like what i'm saying i'm saying i was
like i'm saying like like basketball
right men statistically in every single
i'm sorry it's not a fun reality but
statistically like like in every single
category are better than women like
there's
like really good high school teams that
beat wnba teams all the time
like
but that's what we need but we we want
credit yeah that's good we want we could
cut out the comparison of being seen as
a man so what if i what if i said you
play what if i say you play like lebron
james would you be offended no because
so
i wouldn't i wouldn't be offended but
i'd be like so
my
my gifts and my talents are overlooked
to be compared to
an nba player yes
great nba player but i'd be like can i
not be can i not play like jessica can i
not play like me like i understand what
you're saying but just the fact that
women can't be be like oh she's a great
player she she plays like herself like i
wonder how long she took the train blah
blah to get there but to be compared to
a man it's like okay why can't i why
can't i give you compared to lisa
i just don't understand why it's a bad
thing if they're if they're good like
we just i don't i don't think about it
as women like me personally i can say i
got complimented in the comparison of a
woman right and that was the best
feeling in the world because i was
playing beach volleyball one day yeah
and this guy on the court was like no
you're black serena williams but in
volleyball yeah i was like but you were
you you but you weren't offended by that
because because she was a woman and she
paved away for female 1 but i'm saying
like a man
women's take losses every year in
profits who's making the profits that i
think
when it comes to money i mean just being
strong enough to want to play a sport
that is male dominated for example like
come on tennis
uh basketball all those things
it always started out with men at some
point they were like all right let's let
women play even baseball they decided
not to let women play baseball and
called it softball yeah like because
they decided to be different like don't
the only time i feel like it's okay to
make extreme
comparisons and differences in the sport
is track that makes sense women are
naturally built different we fully
accept that so we have to make those
exceptions for us and track but in other
sports give women a little bit more
credit
you know we we haul ass too
so they hold it down
yeah like if we look at there's a lot of
women there's a lot of female like if
we're going to talk about basketball or
anything i'm probably commenting on
volleyball i don't really attend to it
like that but like even in basketball um
even football
there's a lot of female players that
actually play better than a lot of men
plays but you never say you'll never
catch like a other guy crediting them
like that like
first wait are you talking about soccer
yeah yeah yeah are you talking about
soccer but if but if the women
if the if the women
it's all driven by the market though
like it's driven by by the fans that
want to watch
so so if if women were better than men
like more fans would watch they would
make more money into the sport later way
better is like not the right term like i
think that
like historically like male sports have
dominated and that's kind of the tone
that's set like yeah we can have like a
40 year yeah exactly
also women we don't play like men we
play differently we're correct yes
business and that's genetics yeah we are
like it's volleyball it's completely
different because it's all about yeah
women's volleyball is a lot less like
men's they'll have two rallies and then
it's over because everyone hits so hard
that you can only do so much with it
yeah women's volleyball is a lot
different and that like there's a lack
of interest like women's basketball
you're not going to see girls dunking
every single ball
right
that's not the showboating like you know
what i'm saying so yeah yeah i'm like i
agree i agree yeah i don't appreciate
the i think it's about
tactics i think
obviously men are going to be better
because testosterone is a thing yeah and
they just have more right it's also what
makes them more emotional
yeah i saw that on this again and so but
but i think it's just the point of like
we we already know men are going to be
physically more better than yeah but why
do we have to have that comparison they
may be a great player they may be a
great athlete but why can't there's also
great athletes as women why can't i be
compared to a woman why do i have to be
compared to a man and so i think i'd
rather be compared to a guy in
basketball because they're better but
there's great but there's no a man like
if they said you play like like lebron
james i'd be like dope that's the best
basketball player in the world
up there no i would pick lebron he's
better all person like that's all yeah
yeah yeah
yeah completely your opinion
yeah yeah i know that when i was a
teenager and i first started in
volleyball like i was constantly
compared to guys yeah like initially
because i had a very masculine and
aggressive way of playing as opposed to
just straight tactics so it makes sense
but i did take it as a compliment like i
never had an issue with it because i was
just like gang [ __ ] like yeah
i'm the best
when it came to a point where i realized
like
men don't have to be the pinnacle of
power like that's what it is like i'm
a little tired of that narrative like i
want i don't see it i don't think it's
the narrative i see women in media all
the time
like i see women in like and and online
it's changing i see women definitely
yeah so i don't i don't see men as being
like the pinnacle of like 80 of consumer
buying decisions are by women so we're
all like we are constantly being
marketed for women i feel like i'm just
tired of like okay like when you look at
like commercials and the way that um
sports are showed with like men for
example it's always like them with
gatorade and they're like yeah yeah feel
the burn like not real
you see a 10-pack's commercial and it's
like damn bro like
more than our periods please you can do
your whole life on your period the only
time that you see again like i mentioned
before serena williams like that's like
one of the only athletes that you see in
these commercials like going hard and
going big and it's not about you
the girlfriend track was just in it the
girl from the track team was just in it
the us the us sorry i haven't simone
like no she's not from track wait wait i
can't it's a moan
i was just saying that like they're like
like serena williams like she is so
overly sexualized because she has like a
big ass and she's like a curvy girl and
she's attractive like that bothers me
too because it's like it doesn't focus
on her skill she's insane oh she isn't
sleeping
absolutely
like sexualized in a tennis match it's
like okay i'm gonna start sexualizing
men your balls look real good jiggly
touching on that touching on that there
was a coach i can't remember where she
was from but it was breast cancer
awareness and she had on pink leather
pants and a white top
nothing good she looked great but
someone said is this inappropriate for a
coach i'm like why is that what is it
what if i do
tight pants and you could see stuff and
like is that inappropriate i hate to
bring in racism it's also a racial thing
oftentimes
they have
always sexualize black women and at the
same time masculinize us it makes no
sense and then discriminates against it
it's like what do you want because you
know you really want all of that yeah
it's like
if you're gonna constantly sexualize us
like